oh hello well first of all
congratulations because I know Ford
versus Ferrari it got nominated for Best
Picture very cool very exciting what did
you do when you found out I woke up
really later then did you buy a Ferrari
I did no I did not buy a Ferrari I said
oh yeah it was just so it was nice I
sort of emailed with everyone from the
film and you know I think it's so great
for everyone who was involved you know
it's a lot of love went into that
project so it's it's so nice for
everybody yeah yeah terrific so exciting
yeah so fun yeah so Outlander season 5
people are complaining that y'all made
them wait too long you guys have some
serious fans we did do which is
thankfully why we're still here later
what took so long
well we have to make it well Sam's
makeup takes a very long time yeah you
know we it takes it takes time to make a
show as big and as expensive as ours is
and that is good-looking yeah well
talking about me here and took it in the
shower it's it is nobody's an epic show
isn't it it is and you know there's a
lot of factors you know we are on
location a lot we're outdoors and you
know there's lots of moving parts lots
of horses and not so many Ferraris or
forts so um so it takes a while yeah so
they're gonna just have to they just
have to wait good things come to those
who wait yes what can fans expect in
season 5 I saw a wedding I saw a little
bit of a war mm-hmm what can you tell us
you're winking at me there cuz I know
you got all the tea I gotta split the
tea yes will the tea I'll speed it spill
the tea so I there's there is a wedding
actually there's maybe even more than
one wedding but um ya know the first
episode obviously you know we are we're
established phrases Ridge we're in
in America in North Carolina and you
know really the the the settlement is
flourishing and the family is as well
and um we get to see this this amazing
wedding and and also having said that
there is also this mounting pressure
from the British and and the lead-in to
the Revolutionary War and the war of
independence in yeah it's they're sort
of playing both sides or certainly Jamie
Fraser is playing both sides so um
there's there's the good in the bad
mm-hmm
there are a lot of love scenes between
the two of you what I'm curious about is
at the beginning you know when you're
working with your partner in a scene you
know maybe you brush your teeth or
there's a breath mint or maybe you're
shy in season five do you get to a point
where you just like you don't really
care I'm sorry if I had onion soup
you're gonna deal with it yeah I think
in season one you was that you were
Tobias before the first one had wasn't
me it was Tobias peanut-butter-and-jelly
some was me yeah yeah so I think we
started at a very low point and it could
only have gotten better
twice to something was it yes I've seen
reducing much worse maybe the tuna salad
yeah I think it was something like that
um yeah I mean at this point honestly
where it's like yeah anything you said
before that you two as a couple are the
sexiest couple on the show does that
still ring true in season five
absolutely I did I say that this is a
quote do not make me pull out receipt
where did you find this I found it on
the Internet uh-huh no cause everything
on the internet is true but it is true
we are the sexes couple I think probably
yeah you guys have incredibly passionate
fans what do you think keeps them coming
back every season
well hopefully I think it's it's this
aspirational love story that we have in
the show and you know I think our I
think our show gives the audience a lot
of very different things you know not
only is it a historical drama it has the
romance but it also has a lot of action
and I think people are quite surprised
when they start watching the show that
it is as varied and as multifaceted as
it is and you know I think hopefully
it's good writing and you know good
storytelling as well in the sexiest
couple and great acting oh that's it
yeah you guys you guys make it special
um would you do five more years five
more seasons five more seasons or five
more years five more seasons well that
would be more than five years yeah well
you guys are taking the rise of our line
so no so we've done what six years now
yeah yeah another six years the
approaching 40 by that point I don't
think about it yeah yeah would you watch
for another six seasons possibly
possibly possibly we'll see it's kind of
hot you know things how to get crazy
things have got to get crazy they're not
crazy enough more you want more yeah I'm
just playing your estimate so if you
could take one thing from 2020 and time
travel with it but you only get one
thing in 2020 to take back with you what
would you pick and why one things we
could take one thing back from 24 20 24
now no less and what would you say
mmm I guess getting around my loved one
yeah yeah I think she wins I can say
I'll take a Ferrari because they'll be
kind of cool if you won't be able to
find any petrol no you'll get one run
yeah actually they'll be no ignore roads
really I'm gonna fly
that's right did you take come on you
have to answer no but I would take some
sort you can additive your answer kind
of a better than their like a 4x4 with
like unlimited petrol gas where you guys
call it it's not gas and I would take it
four by four because like everything
takes so long to get to places so four
by four you could unlimited SUV sorry
I'm translating oh go back into the
environment before it even gets a chance
to start or Tesla van
are you gonna plug it in gonna be
useless isn't it I owe them my way I was
like not a camera not a I'm like wow
that's amazing
no good I've got fun Avenue so I think a
car yeah okay
motorbike be good okay I know that you
have been cast to play Paul Newman mmm
very exciting I think that nothing like
him so that's really not true no I
actually we've already shot it and it's
a small part in a movie but it's a very
beautiful movie about Roald Dahl and his
wonderful wife Patricia Neal who's
amazing actress who they both lost their
child and I think it was measles and
it's about sort of them coming to terms
with the loss of their child
and the sort of creativity that comes
out of it and yeah I get to play Paul
Newman for a short time but it's a lot
fun it's a column Cool Hand Luke
you can't quit on Google and some cool
and exam